Remember that this program depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners to exist.
You can grab a membership and support the
show at Join Pakman Dotcom and get the daily
bonus show an extra show just for you.
The Supreme Court, which was held up as a
major, major, major shot at overturning the
election thanks to a bombshell lawsuit for
Donald Trump, has completely anticlimactic,
rejected the case, and this has made Donald
Trump and many of his supporters absolutely
lose their minds.
Now, as a reminder, this was a lawsuit we
discussed last week on the bonus show.
It was a lawsuit by Texas backed by Donald
Trump, suing to throw out or block the voting
results from four different states.
Now, the idea was Texas sued, claiming Georgia,
Michigan, Pennsylvania and Wisconsin were
fraudulent or, as Trump says, fraudulent and
should be prevented from certifying the results,
which officially happens today, December 14th,
and may already have started by the time you
listen to today's show or watch this clip.
The idea was get this to the Supreme Court.
And then Donald Trump's three Supreme Court
picks will defiantly and heroically support
the lawsuit and stop today's electoral vote
certification.
Now, the Supreme Court said no.
Justices said Texas doesn't have standing
to bring the case.
We'll talk more about what standing means
a little bit later.
But this entire bombshell lawsuit that they've
been claiming is going to just interfere and
overturn the results.
It's gone in an instant with the Supreme Court
decision.
The president absolutely lost it.
Check this out.
Donald Trump tweeting that the Supreme Court
chickened out, saying, quote, The fact that
the Supreme Court wouldn't find standing in
an original jurisdiction matter between multiple
states and including the president of the
United States is absurd.
It is enumerated in the Constitution.
They just chickened out and didn't want to
rule on the merits of the case.
So bad for our country.
Now, of course, what's bad for the country
is a president who clearly lost, unwilling
to concede, unwilling to say he will go to
the inauguration, unwilling to admit that
his voter fraud claims are not based.
In fact, that's bad for the country.
Trump then wildly tweeting in all caps.
This went on for hours, really even days.
Most corrupt election in U.S. history.
Trump continuing to go at the Supreme Court
saying that, quote, The Supreme Court had
zero interest in the merits of the greatest
voter fraud ever perpetrated on the United
States of America.
All they were interested in is, quote, standing,
which makes it very difficult for the president
to present a case on the merits, 75 million
votes.
Now, of course, Trump got 75 million, but
Joe Biden got way more and won the Electoral
College.
Trump's White House press secretary and senior
campaign adviser, she's both Kayleigh McEnany
appeared on Fox News with Sean Hannity moments
after the decision on Friday and said the
Supreme Court dodged.
And there's no way to say it other than they
dodged, they dodged, they hid behind procedure,
and they refused to use their authority to
enforce the Constitution.
So look at how quickly no one friends become
enemies for Trump.
This is typical of narcissists.
It's very, very typical.
You're the friend and he's built the greatest
Supreme Court with his three picks.
And thank God Trump got to pick them instead
of Hillary.
Except now the Supreme Court is chicken and
the Supreme Court dodged so very quickly.
Friends become enemies when the paradigm is
narcissism, weaponized narcissism.
And number two, look at how quickly the goalposts
are moved.
First it was we will overturn states with
recounts.
Recounts didn't work.
And then they said, well, right, the recounts
recounted fraudulent ballots.
So of course, the recounts are fraudulent
as well.
We need to throw out ballots.
Couldn't present any evidence.
Every court said no.
So next, it went to prevent certification
by states but state certified.
So it was Sue to block December 14th certification,
go to the Supreme Court.
Supreme Court said no.
Now there were more intermediate steps.
I'm giving you the highlights.
They're irrelevant.
They'd always find more steps, more reasons
to say donate money to us to fight this sort
of fight that there really is no end to it.
The reality is, if you thought it hadn't already
ended weeks ago, we now are at the end.
And at the end of the show, I'll tell you
about today's electoral votes officially being
cast.
They won't be counted in Congress until the
first week of January, presided over by Mike
Pence.
That'll be a day, but we'll talk a little
bit later about what's going
on today.